Congressman Devin Nunez live at the
world egg Expo in California congressman
thank you so much for joining it for
full disclosure I served with you in
Congress while I was there and it's good
for you to be here and joining us here
tonight this happened in the Greater San
Joaquin Valley where the communities are
so tightly knit a lot of farming
activity going on there but I also want
to go back to something happened less
than two weeks ago because also right in
your backyard we had another situation a
gustavo Garcia is accused of this reign
of terror going through the county
remind viewers what happened less than
two weeks ago
well thanks Jason it's great to be on
and let me first say that I have a lot
of friends that live in Newman and so
you know that forest was only I think
there's only 12 officers and so this is
really a tragedy for the valley here the
big San Joaquin Valley which is the AG
region I know you've been here many
times not exactly the way that we want
to spend our holidays so right before
Christmas we had a very similar
situation where there was someone who
was in the country illegally had
actually been deported twice had been
arrested just prior and then was
released because of the sanctuary city
law the sheriff couldn't hold this
Garcia
mr. Garcia who went on a rampage for
over 24 hours
killed two people possibly a third we
don't know because I think there's one
is still in critical condition in the
hospital because this person this Garcia
went around the entire county several
several communities and was shooting
people at random stealing vehicles and
finally caused a major traffic accident
and the car exploded and he's now no
longer part of the planet here but the
bad part is is that there are two
innocents that lost their lives just
like what we experienced in the last
couple days just north of here in Newman
where you had a police officer that was
killed and it's just a horrible
situation and you asked me you know what
can be done I mean the sad part is is
that in the last election in California
these policies were rewarded at the
ballot box so the the Democrats who who
can
these policies had probably their
biggest election whenever and so
something's not making sense I don't
know if people just start getting the
right information that you would think
that at some point politicians would be
held accountable for their actions or
inactions and in this case you know it's
pretty darn clear that that these
sanctuary city policies are leading to
innocent people getting murdered well
and that's the situation with Garcia the
one that happened you know less than two
weeks ago reading you're essentially in
your backyard because this person I
believe had been incarcerated before in
served time for armed robbery
you've been deported twice and still
he's in the hands of law enforcement but
no communication and he's able to come
across the border and that's what's so
infuriating is both of these cases at
least on the surface at least or in the
information we have know both of these
were preventable were they not yeah yeah
no no question that this one I mean this
is a situation where it's even worse the
situation here in our home County in
Tulare County is that you had this
person had actually been deported twice
yeah and so that's the whole challenge
here that's not that the things aren't
adding up you know a lot of the
California border actually has fencing
on it and so the key here is is that
what we've been trying to do in Congress
and what the president's been trying to
do I think very logical solution which
is okay let's take the areas where we
have some fencing that isn't quite
working let's build a wall one that
actually works and those in those
populated areas let's make sure we get
those secured first than other areas you
might not you may not need a wall or
fencing but then at the same time the
president was very reasonable and was
willing to solve the daka problem now we
had a vote in Congress where Republicans
actually voted to build a wall and
reform dhaka
take care of the kids that were brought
here with no part of their own we didn't
get one Democratic vote every Democrat
in the state of California voted against
this law those are for the young people
who live here who would have been made
legal but for some reason people here in
the California I think all over the
country don't realize what a sensible
solution was put on the table
security taking care of Daka putting in
a permit system for people to work here
that are doing jobs that aren't going to
be filled by Americans
very sensible solutions just aren't you
know are not being communicated I think
to the people I think the people are
making some uninformed decisions yeah it
really is amazing that Daka was put on
the table and the Democrats rejected
that but I want to go and play a clip
because it does seem that the Democrats
are against this because Donald Trump is
for it and so it wasn't too long ago
just a few years ago that Chuck Schumer
of the minority leader in the Senate
actually believed in a border wall watch
this day the American people need to
know that because of our efforts in
Congress our border is far more secure
today than it was when we began debating
comprehensive reform in 2005 between
2005 and 2009 a vast amount of progress
has been made on our borders and ports
of entry the progress includes 9,000 new
Border Patrol feel eight field agents in
the last four years construction of a
630 mile border fence or 630 miles of
border fence that create a significant
barrier to illegal immigration on our
southern land border there you go I
could play that all day long
he voted to authorize it but now he's
won't vote in for in in favor of
actually funding it now the congressman
we only have a minute left but you know
Nancy Pelosi is in Hawaii Maxine Waters
is off vacationing in the Bahamas you're
in your district Kevin McCarthy who's
from Baker the bakersfield areas is at
home in his district how does the
president come to a resolution when
Nancy Pelosi is working on her hula as
opposed to actually negotiating
something that's reasonable where does
this go and I'm right here in my and I'm
right here in Tulare County in the world
i expo doesn't get better than this
right here in the AG museum look this is
if i was in hawaii right now i begin i'd
be getting killed if kevin mccarthy the
new republican leader was in was in
hawaii right now he'd be getting crushed
you have president as he's shooting in
Washington DC waiting to cut a deal and
and they're off on vacation I mean look
they never wanted to do a deal they
wanted the government to shut down the
second that Donald Trump said well look
I'll own the shutdown or fine I'll shut
it down they were like okay that's it
we'll get out of town go to Hawaii and
then you know you watch on January 3rd
there when there's a new Congress
they're gonna try to pass something and
they're just gonna this is just gonna
continue and in the meantime problems
are not being solved so the good news is
about all this is that now they will
have a responsibility to put legislation
on the floor that will fix these
problems that they've been unwilling to
vote with Republicans or support the
President's agenda to fix well
congressman thanks for your great work I
do think that the Democrats want the
issue more than they actually want to
solve the problem and I also wish that
the Senate would vote on the bill that
the House passed remember the House
passed the five billion dollars it's the
Senate that's not doing it and I plead
with the majority majority leader in the
Senate put them on their record make
them actually vote let's see who
actually stands for the border and who
doesn't and you can only do that by
actually holding a vote because the end
of the hundred and fifteen Congress is
about to expire on January third but
congressman thank you for joining us
tonight and spending some time with us
we do appreciate it